you climbed to the top of the corporate
ladder you're on a very well-paid job I
mean quit that I wasn't excited to get
out of bed to do my job now I can't wait
to start working on my business how much
is your business now turning over and
what's the portfolio size close to a
quarter of a million the portfolio it's
worth about 3.2 million now I'm creating
beautiful places for them to kerit and
to create memories with their families
that's just super exciting for me 750 a
night and you're paying a grand a month
from the rent how much does that
turnover then 7K a month and when you
know the rules of the game then play to
win and I just thought what have I got
to lose it's one day it's 1 even if I
don't learn anything I've not really
lost anything when you regreted quitting
the job did you ever think oh my gosh I
should never have done
that Holly welcome to winners on a
Wednesday thank you so you're a business
leader for the last 10 years yeah
financially free yeah from the cot WS
yeah talk to me about your background
cuz you climbed to the top of the
corporate ladder you on a very well-paid
job and then quit that and shocked
everybody if you'd have asked me at the
time should I quit I'd have said
absolutely not but you quit a very high
paid job to go fulltime into property
and basically started from from the
ground up so talk to me about your
background in in in in corporate world
well I did a psychology degree to begin
with I wasn't really sure where I wanted
to go but I sort of ended up in HR for
the last close to 20 years since I
finished University and I kind of worked
my way up climbed that corporate ladder
and to to be honest at the beginning of
that career journey I really ened
enjoyed it I really enjoyed the
challenge of climbing the ladder but I
think as I got further and further and
towards the top it the balance kind of
shifted for me I'm at a stage now in my
life where I've got two young children a
three-year-old and a 5-year-old and I
really wanted to be able to be um a mom
that was present for my children and I
think you know getting to where I got to
in my career as a HR Director I just
wasn't able to to strike that balance it
was a global role and so it kind of
never stopped for me so yeah it just got
to a point where I just wasn't happy it
wasn't for me anymore and I knew for a
while I needed to make a change um I'd
always had a passion for property my
husband and I have done a couple of
development projects in the past and
we'd always said would do more um but
it's that old cliche we never kind of
found the right time and that was always
something we like oh maybe we we'll do
it next year maybe we'll do it next year
we just never did it but I think I got
to a point of 18 months ago where I was
just super frustrated with work and I
I've got to make a change so I started
Googling so found yourself yeah and I
guess the rest is history from yeah well
I think you watched a Financial Freedom
challenge I did what happened when you
were watching the video talk to me about
that it was evans's Financial Freedom
challenge I remember that very well I
bet you do um and I guess just really
opened my eyes to what was possible and
I think when you see somebody go from
almost nothing to financially free in
seven days it just blows your mind and
you're like oh my God and and also I
think you sit there and you think well
hold on a minute if that person can do
it why can't ask right yeah and I think
you know when you see that kind of
success it gives you or it gave me the
confidence and it wasn't just that I I
come along to some training I'd met you
I kind of started to understand some of
the strategies before I took the
decision to leave my job and I just knew
that I would be able to make a success
of it with the right education um I had
that confidence because of the academy
and because of the people around me and
because of what i' seen you can't unsee
that right yeah you just can't unsee no
you can't so I often find a lot of
people that are in corporate jobs that
have have worked their way up and you
were you know making six figures a year
doing really well they're the hardest
people to coach because normally they're
so risk averse because they've got
accustomed to you know that lifestyle
couple cars holidays kids house mortgage
and and and going from that to going
into property and being a property
sometimes it's really difficult because
they're so comfortable what made you
decide to transition and qu your job
yeah it's a really good question and I
think you know just to expand on what
you're saying there you almost become
trapped yes because you've got that you
you're that comfortable you've got a
good salary and you know to all intents
and purposes for everybody looking in
you've got a good job and why would why
would you quit but for me um it was that
work life balance it was a high pressure
job high stress and there's more to life
like I knew that um I wanted to do
something that I was excited to get out
of bed every morning for I wasn't
excited to get out of bed to do my job
now I can't wait to start working on my
business every morning and it's just
such a change and also to have the
flexibility to be around for my kids to
pick them up from school to drop them
off to you know to do the things the
assemblies or whatever it might be and
to create something that's that's mine
as well yeah um I think that for me that
was why I did it I think the other thing
is I knew I knew that I could be
successful having watched the academy
and the videos and and started some of
the training but I also knew that I
needed to give myself the opportunity to
focus on it and having such a busy job
and two children I knew if I've invested
in this Academy training I needed to
give myself the opportunity to be
successful with it and I couldn't do
that in this job that I had as well so
for a lot of people you know it's I
think probably the sensible approach is
to um try and sort of build it up
alongside you that's what we teach yeah
and you just be like nah but it's worked
I mean now how much is your business now
turning over and what's the portfolio
size so it's close to a quarter of a
million a year turnover a year turnover
um the portfolio so it's a mixture of
owned managed and controlled um and it's
worth about 3.2 million that's
incredible wow and you've been
absolutely killing it and hopefully
having fun doing it yeah 100% 100% I
actually sometimes I have to pinch
myself it's a little bit indulgent I
find because I love Really Love U the
design the creating spaces like I've
always been um a big advocate of
traveling and and getting experiences in
new places myself I love going to to
visit places with character and for me
now I have the opportunity to create
that for other people in the north cot
Worlds the market is primarily tourism
and so I know that you know I'm creating
beautiful places for them to come and
and to create memories with their
families and that's just super exciting
for me and yeah like I say I feel like
it's a little bit indulgent because I
really enjoy it it's almost like should
I be getting paid for this well that's
exactly what life's for isn't it if you
can get paid for doing something that
you love never work a day in your life
how's life changed then so you're a mom
you got two kids what does the average
day look like now compared to how it did
a year ago for me I've always been a
morning person I like to get up and go
that hasn't changed so we get up early
as a family anyway the kids are off to
school preschool and I start my day um I
generally um I'm looking for new
opportunities new business um through um
looking for properties on on might be
right move it might be open rent
speaking to landlords direct I do a bit
of that on a daily basis got a number of
properties that we're obviously actively
managing in our portfolio a lot of that
is systemized so I don't have to spend a
huge amount of time there but I do like
to make sure I'm keeping an eye on
things and make sure that they're
running uh as I as I would want them to
be and the guest experience is what I
want it to be so I do that on a daily
basis as well um but I've got a lot more
free time to kind of focus on the things
that I want to do so you know it was
half term just a week or so ago and I
was able to take that time with the kids
I was still doing a bit of work on those
days but I was able I'm flexible enough
now to take that week off so yeah I mean
it's massively changed in terms of just
getting up and being able to do
something that I really enjoy and every
day is different you know if we are
actively taking a property live some of
the things I've just talked about they
wouldn't be a priority we'd be we'd be
more focused on designing and and
staging the property sourcing things for
our clients or or for the properties
that we've got what's your kind of
natural flare then what's your sort of
your unique USP where is it that you're
most happy what is it that you're best
at impr because in property there's so
much there's so many things you could do
the pie is so big as you say you've got
properties you own you manage you
control what's the where are you most
successful or flourishing so um right
now where I'd say where we're most
successful is our service accommodation
business and I really understand the
market in the cot world and the
different areas um so and before I did
any of the Academy training I just
wouldn't I wouldn't have known that you
have different types of guests in your
service accommodation I just assumed um
that it would be tourism I'm in the cot
worlds I just thought that's the only
kind of people that would use uh your
accommodation and obviously since doing
the training I've learned there's
there's so many different types of
guests that you can have so there might
be contractors there might be relocators
professionals that want to use your
property on a short stay basis and so
I've gotten to really understand the
market in the cost cotw worlds certain
areas are driven primarily by tourism
and it's a year- round destination but
there are other parts of the cotw worlds
for example Gloucester City which is
just on the edge where there's a huge
amount of development going on in
glester at the moment lots of money
being pumped into that City and there's
just so much demand for accommodation
for contractors so we've got a number of
apartments in in Gloucester and we've um
staged them we've made sure we've got
the right facilities that contractors
need when they're on a job so like it's
really getting to understand the market
and then making Ure that what we've got
in those properties is really delivering
what our our guests need yeah and it's
so important to know your area well it
really is and that's why I think that
you should have a patch like you've got
because a lot of people get drawn in by
the cheaper areas they might think oh
wow Liverpool you can buy a house for
Liverpool for like 80 grand yeah all
Grimsby and they're really attracted by
these uh cheaper northern areas which
are great if you live there and if
that's your strategy but actually the
fact that you've made made it work so
well in the cot WS which is not a cheap
area no it's it's a pretty expensive
area but you've understood the market
You' found your Niche and and are now
dominating in the space yeah is is great
yeah and and you know we have got a a a
decent sized portfolio now majority of
that is controlled or or rent to rent so
the next step for us we continue to grow
in that space but we also want to start
developing now as well in the area and
you're right you know we absolutely were
we toyed with the idea of do we invest
up north because it is cheaper so the
barrier to entry is lower but I think
when you know your location and you know
a strategy then you know now I can
combine the strategy of service
accommodation with brr and you know
really make some serious money and
that's what you're doing and another
thing that you've done really
successfully which I think that is a
little bit untapped and people aren't
aware of is just straight management
yeah because there's quite a lot of
money in management yeah and it's it's
the the barrier to entry is low yeah
it's even lower than if you do rent to
rent if you think about it because you
don't have to risk any money no in
management no you're just providing a
service if it doesn't rent out worst
that can happen is the Investor's going
to be a bit cheesed off yeah but you're
not guaranteeing any rent no how do you
do that then what does how does that
work so if you're managing a proper do
you only manage service accommodation
properties I do only manage service
accommodation so I'm focused that's my
specialist area I know the clientele I
know what people need and also you know
when it comes to places like Gloucester
I've got relationships with business is
there that you know that need
accommodation so I know that I can fill
those apartments or those houses in that
area I think it is just about
understanding your location at the end
of the day and I think as well with you
having a niche you can now package and
sell deals in the area you can develop
properties in the area yeah brr
development you can you can do rent to
rent in the area when you've got that
knowledge and understanding of an area
yeah and what's really nice is that I've
um a couple of trusted Partners so that
if I've got an investor that's
interested in working with us whether
that's via the management side of things
where we you know we just we manage the
property for them we charge a fee for
that on a monthly basis um or whether
it's it's something else we can offer an
endtoend service so I I work closely
with people who are able to Source those
opportunities I'm able to Stage them and
then I'm able to manage them so it can
be a complete hands off for somebody if
they're interested in things have you
had any nightmare guests do you know
what I think I've been super lucky I've
not had any nightmare guests we do take
guest ID we've got agreements in place
um you know clear policies uh for for
our guests in terms of what they can and
can't do if they were to breach those
you know we'd be there straight away to
to make sure that either they stopped
what they were doing or they were exited
from from the property I think as well
for us particularly it's the location
that we're operating in so the
Cals generally speaking you're not
getting younger guests that may be
having parties there's less of that in
the CWS so the the type
market area it's more market and there's
if you've got an area where it is a
little bit more down Market if you
understand that and and you could
potentially C to that or you could
prevent certain things about knowing
your area exactly and I think the other
thing is you know we don't allow one
night stays in any of our accommodations
why why do you not and why is that so
important that's super important because
I think if you're going to throw a party
which is where things get broken and
neighbors get upset then you want
somewhere for a one night's day so yeah
we don't allow one what the minimum St
well it depends on the location but for
our Gloucester City Apartments where you
probably more likely to get parties
they're generally a minimum of five
nights day oh wow and that's because
we're targeting professionals
contractors families um that are staying
in the area for either they're
relocating or they're working so you
might lose some bookings because there
might be some genuine good clients that
just want to stay for a night or two
they might but it's the risk verse
reward isn't it 100% 100% so you're
getting IDs people up front yeah that's
going to eliminate a lot of bad tenant
parties crazies because they're having
to give you an ID exactly you're saying
minimum night day of X am amount of
nights depending on the area is there
anything else tips to prevent because
that's one of the biggest issues people
have you know what there's so many plus
sides to service accommodation shorts
daylet you're going to get way more rent
it's way more tax efficient there's just
so many advantages you could you could
make three four five times as much but
everyone's
scared but I might get a party going on
I might get a bad so that's why I'm
asking you to hopefully eliminate some
people's fears around some of the things
that you might do to prevent that yeah
100% And and I think that there are so
many things you can do you can have ring
cameras so you can see people coming in
and out you can have um noise detectors
in in your apartment so that you can
detect if if there's all of a sudden
making um a lot of noise by playing loud
music you can that you get an alert on
your phone and you know your clean will
get the alert on her phone or the
cleaning's getting alert on their phone
yeah so there just so many things I
think whatever is worrying you or
holding you back there's always an
answer to it there's always something
you can do a process that you can put in
place um that means that you can you can
manage that you can mitigate that risk
and then the reward absolutely outweighs
the risk and also with ten normal
tenants if they're trashing the place or
if they're not paying the rent you're
quite powerless 100% And the reality is
you know and I and I often have this
conversation with with landlords s if
you renting if you're renting to a a
company like myself you know it's in my
best interest to make sure that that
property is looked after it's kept in
tiptop condition because otherwise my
business model doesn't work if you're
renting to a residential tenant they
don't really care if the property is
looked after because they're there for a
short-term State they haven't invested
in the property they don't own it and
sometimes you get bad tenants
unfortunately and it's really difficult
to get them out you know you're stuck
with them so so yeah I mean from a
landlord's perspective working with a
company that's doing short day
accommodation I you know I always have
that conversation they're actually
better protected with somebody like
myself than they are with a residential
tenant was there ever a moment Hollow
when you regretted quitting your job did
you ever think oh my gosh I should never
have done that I think and it's
important to to to share these sorts of
things because I think it can help
others along their Journey it didn't
happen quickly for me um I so I made
that decision and I was really confident
that it was going to work um and i' you
know you see a lot of success on the
academy it's a great environment to be
in it gives you that motivation um but
for me it took I think it was about four
months for me to get my first rent to
rent deal over the line and when we did
get that one over the line we had two
months rent free we needed it needed
quite a lot of TLC so it took me six
weeks to get that one live and then it
took me a little little while longer to
to get my next one U I think it was
another another few months maybe to get
my next one but I think one once I got
that second one things really started to
change for me it gave me the confidence
and I was just able to progress a lot
more quickly I think you know for
anybody out there that's maybe just
started and struggling to begin with you
know sometimes you do see quite a lot of
success well not sometimes you always
see a lot of success surrounded
surrounded by it and it can be a bit
disheartening at times whil it's
motivational because you're like well if
they're doing it I can do it too if
you're you know keep getting the nose
you it can be a little bit difficult
especially I think if you're working by
yourself I've been working by myself in
the business I great support from my
family but day-to-day working by myself
so and when you keep getting that nose
it can be difficult to kind of pick
yourself up and go right no this is
going to work keep going so I mean and I
had that persistance and you know I got
the first deal I got the second deal but
then that that's the point for me the
Tipping Point it gave me the confidence
and then I was able to to go live with
another eight properties you know then
next five months so it happens it
doesn't happen quickly for everybody
that's okay we're all on our own journey
I think before i' got the second
property I I was kind of saying to my
husband maybe I need to take some
contract work or something um just to
ease the pressure that I was putting on
myself I've walked away from this job
and the salary that comes with it uh to
to nothing to no income from from me and
I was in a lucky position my husband
Could You Know cover the bills and
everything so we weren't in D but still
you put that pressure on yourself yeah
um so yeah there definitely was a point
at which I I kind of worried you know
did I did I go at this too quickly but
it turned around it's a really difficult
one to answer when people ask me we were
talking about this off camera because I
get people s to the time shall I quit my
job yeah and it's such a personal
decision isn't it and it also depends on
well the first question I often ask
people is well do you enjoy your job
yeah if you love your job you you know
I'm sure you enjoyed many elements to it
but you said you were feeling a little
bit trapped and wanted to be with the
kids more and you kind of felt like you
need to get out but you know do you
enjoy it can you afford to you had your
husband who was also working which took
the pressure off a little bit um it it's
a very personal decision it is and I
think it's you know obviously it's about
about whether you can manage financially
and you don't want to do anything silly
that's going to put yourself um in a in
a difficult situation but for me it was
also about how I work and the job that I
had was a very very sort of high
pressure high stress very long hours and
I just wouldn't have been able to give
him to give myself the opportunity to be
successful if I didn't say right I've
got to cut the cord almost here and say
right now I've got the time to focus a
tip that I do give some people though
which is a bit of an in between yeah
people like in your situation they're
saying like I'm working crazy hours I
just can't focus on property I'll say
book a week off and do a Financial
Freedom challenge yeah go mad for a week
yeah unpaid leave holiday whatever and
in that week you'll be amazed at what
you can achieve you might end up a
couple deals and actually this is kind
of working now I can quit whereas if on
that week you're like I didn't get
anything that was horrible then maybe
stay for a little bit longer it would
just give you that little bit of but
then some people do I mean I mean I
definitely wouldn't advise I don't think
it's sensible to just quit your job I
know I did it but it was more about me
just being able to I knew I wasn't happy
where I was I knew I needed to make a
change and and I work better under
pressure that's just how I how I work
question for you if you got 100 Grand
cash and you want to invest it in the C
WS what would you cuz I know you help
people do that yeah what's the best way
to invest a 100 Grand right now into the
cot worlds would you say so the CWS is a
really um I guess a little bit unique to
the rest of the country and there's
Pockets like the CWS all around but it's
not really impacted by a downturn in
Market there's it's a really strong um
own bub Market yeah it's got its own
little bubble but there are still some
prop well there's quite a lot of
properties in the cotw worlds where
there's an opportunity to push value up
to do development and that's where we're
going to be focusing in our sort of next
step now you've got your experience
totally under rups of of the management
side exactly exactly so we are going to
be growing the management side but we're
also going to start to look for our
first brr okay buying something well um
something that we can push the value up
and and effectively turn that into
service accommodation because we know
that works really well so if I was
saying to somebody you've got 100 if
you've got 100 Grand what would you do
with it that's what I would recommend
they do buy something because you know
you've got really strong capital
appreciation in that area and and that's
just going to continue plus you can you
can achieve that super rent through your
service accommodation so will cash flow
really well for you so you've got the
best of both worlds sure so you buy
something what for maybe like 300 Grand
like a rundown dilapitated building yeah
You' obviously use part of your 100
Grand to put as a deposit maybe Bridge
the difference yeah refurb the heck out
of it yeah would you turn into flats or
would you do it as one big house um I
would split the property um to maximize
the revenue you can get from a service
accommodation um I maybe Flats we'd have
to do we always want to do our due
diligence whatever we're doing to make
sure that we understand how the
properties would let out in that area
but better than Flats um in the cot
worlds is maybe splitting a property so
you've got two like Terrace houses okay
so you've got a bigger because the
bigger properties that are like two or
three bedrooms went really well on a
service accommodation basis and if
you've got a little bit of outside space
as well that's really really good and
then you rent it out of service to come
shorts toets who are your guests then in
the CWS are they there's a lot of
Tourism there there's there's a huge
amount of tourism in the cot worlds um
obviously the summer is just crazy like
100% occupancy in the summer um but you
get a lot of families and you get a lot
of couples that come uh walk in just
want to um go and see the see the sites
there's a lot of history in the cot
walls we get quite a lot of Americans uh
Japanese Chinese people coming as
tourists how much are they paying then
for a week a week St a nice three bed
house in the CWS so we have a place in
in Morton and Marsh uh it's got flexible
bedrooms or sitting sitting rooms so
it's like four bedrooms and they it
depends so our nightly rate is anywhere
between 260 in the low season right up
to 750 at night 750 a night yeah geez
yeah and the properties that you're
renting that you're doing is rent to
rent in the cost WS how much are you
paying rent give me give give me a case
study of one of your rent to rents so
the one I was just talking about was
actually my first rent to rent deal the
one that took me a long time to get over
uh the line and um when we took it on it
needed TLC so we did a big uh renovation
how much you spend uh we invested about
10 grand in okay so quite a hefty amount
but then you did get a grace period of
how long so we got a grace period of two
months okay good and we actually have it
on a commercial lease for 6 years jeez
so this is a property that we've got for
the long term so we knew we get our
money back that's why we were
comfortable with the investment also we
just knew because it's in a really good
location in Mort Marsh right in the
center and like I said it's a bigger
property so it's flexible we'd also
negotiated the rent down so it's only
like ,000 a month okay um and so we knew
that it would cash flow really well even
if you just had a couple staying in
there and you and you bought your U
nightly rate down so that's what we do
we actually advertise it in two ways we
advertise it as a larger property for
larger groups and also just as a
slightly smaller property for smaller
families and we've got two nightly rate
so we're able to flex it quite well from
that perspective and that really
maximizes our occupancy yeah that's
clever yeah yeah and how much do you
charge for that then a night so that one
is the one that's kind of between the
260 to 750 a night so 750 a night and
you're paying a grand a month on the
rent how much does that turn over then
that property generally speaking the 750
night is when we've got groups of like 8
9 10 sure um we have fewer of those
bookings um and so you know we we we
might let it out for two three or four
nights at that rate and then the rest is
at a lower rate 260s are base it's
normally a little bit more than that but
that probably um it's about 6 and a half
7K a month it does forine so the profit
on that is how much it's about three
three grand a month profit after bills
and you're cleaning and I mean the big
question that a lot of people will get
and there's a very simple answer is a
lot of people will say why doesn't why
don't everyone just do that why don't
all the landlords just went but it's not
easy when you don't know how like you
were talking about getting all the photo
ID getting all the alarms um it's it's
it's a business yeah it's a business and
for me like I just didn't even know that
you could do that like I'd always wanted
to have a service accommodation business
it's something that I talked to my
husband about for a few years turning
our house into service accommodation but
we just we hadn't done it and I just
didn't understand about this strategy of
rent to to rent I didn't know I could
rent something on a long-term basis on a
commercial agreement effectively because
I'd only heard of or had knowledge of a
so I think when you educate yourself it
just opens so many doors but also in my
experience some of the best landlords
are people that have tried to do Airbnb
them themselves have tanked therefore
they've clearly got the right type of
mortgage for it they understand that
they're up for it but then we rent it
from them and do it as Airbnb and
booking.com but we do it properly yeah
yeah and then they're just like you know
what I know you're making a couple Grand
a month off of it you deserve it because
we tried and we failed they skipped the
class yeah exactly and I think if you
don't treat it like a business and you
think it's just something you're going
to do on the side you're not going to
put any effort in it will it won't make
the money that you want to if you don't
put the right systems in place yeah I
mean because there is a downside and
that is if you don't take the photo ID
and you do one night minimum stay and
you don't split it and understand who
your Market is and you don't have the
sound alarms you don't have good
cleaners and then you have an absolute
horrible nightmare 100% where you're
losing money so it's not just the time
spent on it I think it's setting up in
the right way and I I noticed as well a
lot of people that just Outsource it um
you have obviously got a management
company but if you just pass it to a
management company without checking that
management company out properly first
seeing their experience making sure that
they are Specialists makeing sure their
specialists in the area often the
management companies will be rubbish
yeah and then ah it don't work it it
does work it just doesn't work because
you don't know how to do it you're just
passing it to a management company blind
leading the blinds it's a business it's
a business that's it and you've got to
do your research even if it's so you're
either doing your own due diligence so
you know how to Market it or if you've
not got the time for that and you
passing it to somebody else you've got
to do your due diligence on the
individual that's going to be marketing
it and managing it for you because
otherwise yeah it's going to fall F
people could say when they look at
Premier in who you do the same business
model so Premier in will rent a building
on a company let for a 10 20 year lease
and then they'll run it as a premier in
say oh why doesn't the owner of the
building just do that because they don't
want to they haven't got the time they
haven't got the inclination they haven't
got the experience they haven't got the
systems and procedures in place they'd
rather just get their flat guaranteed
rent and that's the case with a lot of
landlords Holly talk to me about how you
pitch a
landlords on giving you their properties
on rent to rent because that's something
that is a massive stumbling block for
people on the early days yeah you're
always going to have challenges yeah in
business your challenges will change we
just hit the ACP which we'll talk about
in a few minutes but at the acpp um the
challenges were I'm paying too much tax
yeah I've now got to go vat registered
yeah and we had a big brainstorming
session as to what we could potentially
do about that but just got to pay the V
yeah you know you might have challenges
you've guests but the first challenge I
think most people have is getting a
landlord to give them their property
yeah on a company L rent to rent
agreement help us out so I think it's
all about trust at the end of the day um
you know you've got your giving so a
landlord is giving you a property
something that they've probably invested
in themselves in terms of they might
have done a renovation on it or or at
the very least theyve bought it so their
cash is in that property um and they
want to know it's going to be looked
after um so for me I think that is the
biggest thing that that I leverage and
we touched upon it a little bit already
that you know a residential tenant isn't
necessarily looking after that property
whereas we absolutely will be because
we're in there before and after every
tenant it's professionally cleaned we
often and and something that's worked
well for me in the cotw worlds because
it's a hard Market in the cworld in the
north cworld so the cotw worlds towns
and Villages that are tourism there's a
lot of money there's a lot of second
homes they don't need to rent their
properties out these second home they
just sit empty so is a it's a tough
Market to crack and I've been able to
build relationships with estate agents
in in the local area that will pass me
opportunities which is has been great
but when you're having that one-on-one
conversation with a landlord it is about
getting building that trust and helping
them to understand the model helping
them to understand the value that you're
bringing in terms of looking after their
property and investing in their property
we just talked about Morton in Marshall
we invested 10K there it wasn't just a
liquor paint you know we put new sink in
we put new shower in we don't own that
property they're getting all the benefit
from that we probably push the value up
on that property for the LA and we're
going to look after it and keep it to
that standard for the next six years um
you know so for me it becomes a little
bit of a no-brainer if if you're a
landlord and you've got an opportunity
to either work with a company that's
going to really look after invest in
your property push the value up you know
it's hands hands off for them they don't
have to worry it's guaranteed rent and
that's another thing we talk about you
know every month they're getting their
money in the bank there's no void
periods for them when they're changing
uh residential tenants they don't have
to worry about looking for tenants every
six or 12 months as we often do the just
so many positives for a landlord to work
with a company like like USS and like
others than there is renting on a just a
normal standard residential a and you're
paying them normally a similar amount if
not a little bit more in some cases
because we can afford to it's a
no-brainer yeah it's a no-brainer yeah
so I guess what you've just said is
you've listed all the benefits to the
landlord and it's important that you go
in armed like that cuz when you go in
you're speaking to a landord if you're
thinking this is going to make me two
grand a month oh I hope the all agrees
oh what I'm doing is a little bit
naughty though if if if you're thinking
that the's not going to do because if
you think actually what's in it for them
yeah you just listed all the benefits
for them and then of course there's
benefits for you and it's win-win yeah
so how are you approaching these anals
are you like like how did you find that
first deal did you find it through an
agent did you find I found it on right
move and it was via an agent um so that
one um and then the others are direct to
the landlord how do you how do you get
in touch with the landlord direct so
those are normally because they're
advertising on open rent and so I'll go
through open rent and open rent for that
doesn't know is a bit like right move
but where you're dealing with the
landlords direct yeah exactly that so
yeah so you can scroll through you can
do a search on a specific area scroll
through see any properties that meet
your criteria and then give them a
message I always try and get their
number um and then give them a call and
have an open and honest conversation
with them to talk to them about what I
want to do and and book of viewing with
them and I will have a bit of a
conversation with them about the
benefits and the value that we bring
straight away so that you know I think
it's so important that you're managing
expectations and that you're being uh
honest with with the landlords of course
yeah um so because otherwise I think you
know you you turn up and they think it's
just a normal let or I say normal but a
residential it's not pretty when you do
that no because because then the
landlord will feel tricked yeah exactly
and that's not what we want we want to
build that trust we want them to
understand the model and the value that
we bring you know we're not going into
huge amounts of detail but we're having
that conversation to begin with
um and then going and having the viewing
and and just building on that building
the report how do you deal with
rejection so when you get landlords just
shooting you down on the phone or saying
like oh absolutely not oh I've had calls
like this before or just just rude yeah
how do you as a person how do you deal
with that does it does it hurt sometimes
it
hurts just honestly sometimes it hurts
and especially I think at the beginning
you know where you're just not as
resilient and you haven't had the yeses
to combat some of those NOS you do you
put the phone down and think oh God is
it ever you know are we going to get and
that's also the importance of being in
the right environment because I say like
when because we we do a lot of these
calls on training so when you come to
like the rent to rent training that will
be on the phone when you I've I've not
been a delegate of the course because
I'm I'm a trainer but I imagine I'd like
to think from what I've heard when
everyone's making calls and everyone's
getting
rejected but then you're getting yeses
and when you're around other people and
you winning and it's fun and it's it's
much easier to do it than when you're
just at home yeah on your kitchen table
7:00 p.m. in the evening if you getting
nose but everyone's just like oh well
next next next and you're under that
pressure healthy pressure positive
environment it's kind of easier deal
persistence is so important and you have
to keep picking yourself back up and
saying no I've got something at Value
that I'm bringing to the table here um
and there will be that the right
landlord that I'm speaking to at some
point because it isn't right for
everybody and that's the other thing
you've just got to know yeah you know
some landlords they've got other plans
for their properties and that's fine it
doesn't have to be right for everybody
you just need one yes to begin with and
it can life changing one deal I was
checking with a guy recently who did the
rent to crash calls with us and he said
oh man I've called so many landlords I'm
getting so much rejection and when we
actually looked at his phone history in
that he' made it I think four calls and
it's like come on bro we then made some
calls together on the program and he got
yes but it took him another like 10
calls to get a yes and he said but the
nine rejections that I got felt like
nothing cuz when he said when I was at
home and I was getting rejected my
partner was going I told you I told you
every time he was getting a note was
like I told you it's not what you need
if you're at home and you've got a
partner saying told you every time of
course it's going to feel like you've
made loads of calls so give your give
yourself the best Advantage you know the
slight Edge by getting in the right
environment oh 100% And for me that was
you know one of the biggest things uh
and one of the biggest reasons I joined
the academy cuz I knew I was going to be
working by myself in the business and I
knew I needed to put myself in that
environment where I could see the
success and also on the days that you're
not feeling great you've got that
support network as well yeah so people
lift you up and that's that's one of the
best things about the academy it's just
a really positive environment yeah and I
tell you what the last Academy training
we did at the acpp which was two days
coaching at my house yeah um it was just
I think every single person in the room
was making at least three grand it's
just crazy and everybody's really just
started their journey in terms of on
their first year there was 22 people I
believe yeah and the average person was
making about six seven Grand a month
from property and we went around the
room you know I did that little video
just like man when you're in that it's
hard to fail I think when it's normal
yeah you have in life what you accept
what you tolerate I found this a little
bit of my weight as well like if I'm
hanging before obviously as you know I
lost quite a bit of weight but before if
I if you tolerate if you think I'm not
too bad I'm only a little bit of Beast
you know if you accept it yeah then
that's what you're going to have you're
you're having life exactly what you
tolerate and if you don't tolerate
anything but success in your business
everyone around you is winning and
that's the standard and I'm not going to
tolerate I'm not going to tolerate less
than that then that's what you'll that's
what you'll get yeah so what excites you
the most
then I am super excited just for for the
future because you know I when I look
back on what I've achieved in the last
N9 months and it feels you know super
quick it took me years to climb this
corporate ladder that I climbed in my in
my HR career and now all of a sudden in
nine months I've created the business
that I have so for me I'm just super
excited about now I've got a business
and I've got a plan to really scale that
business and really create something
that's life-changing for me and my
family I just I'm so excited about that
you've done so super well it's
interesting as well isn't it w with the
training programs like you come to a
crash course everyone's background's so
different but they're all at the same
starting point like you could be making
300 Grand a year and be this you know
the director of a massive company of 100
members of Staff underneath you and you
could be someone who just topped out of
University age 19 but you kind of
starting yeah and you know what I like
that I really liked having the
opportunity to just start again it's
quite it's like I think it's very
humbling for everybody just to be on at
the same starting point the same level
because we've all got the same
opportunity for success and I think you
know for some people it might be
difficult to say well you know I've been
this successful leader you know I don't
want to start down here again but I I
think that's that's a mistake that's
crazy to have that point of view you've
got to be flexible if you want to be
successful in life and you want to have
other opportunities you've got to be
flexible enough to take that step down
if you like or just to take yourself out
of that crazy stressful position that
you were in before and start at the
beginning and it's do you know what it's
a fun Journey as well it's a fun Journey
it's a fun Journey yeah it is what will
be your biggest piece of advice to
someone watching this if they just
starting out I think the thing that sort
of held me back for a few years before I
got to to getting onto the academy
academy is that I always thought it
wasn't the right time to start a
property business so for me I think I
would say to others there's never a
right time just need to get the
education so you know how to play the
game regardless of what's going on in
the market and then just get started
because you can make so many excuses for
yourself as to why you're not going to
do it yeah but the reality is if you
don't start you know you'll never learn
you got you just got to get started
that's so true it's never a bad time to
learn the rules of the game no and when
you know the rules of the game you can
then play to win exactly and you'll
realize actually there isn't a perfect
time no now's the perfect time always a
perfect when was your first crash course
then it was last summer so I think May
June time um that I I I remember having
a particularly stressful frustrated day
at work and I was like oh I just don't
want to do this anymore so I started
Googling I'd heard about the rent to
rent strategy I didn't really understand
it so I was Googling I was like maybe I
can do that whilst I'm you know still
doing this job um and so I started
Googling that and that's when I came
across yourself um and straight away I
was researching you i' signed up to your
365 got your books and I was like right
well I'll go on U I'm just going to go
sign up to one of these one pound crash
courses I couldn't believe it was a
pound and I was just like well what have
I got to lose it's one day it's one
pound even if I don't learn anything
I've not really lost anything it's just
a day and I learned so much in that one
day and I was absolutely buzzing um I
came away I'd already decided to do the
BR training because that's really kind
of where my passion's always been and
where I wanted to get to and so yes it
was last last June I think that I came
to the crash course then I did the BR
course in September middle of September
last year that's where I signed up for
the academy and then I've done the 12
month September end of September to to
12 montho w well it's been an absolute
journey and I know this is also just the
beginning yeah so um what would be your
advice to someone that's considering
coming to the 1 pound crash course but
they've not been and they're just like
oh what I'm I'm on the fence yeah
absolutely crazy noty why wouldn't you
spend one day it's research I'm sure you
know we all sit at home Googling or
researching online for hours and yes
okay that hasn't necessarily cost you
anything but it's a pound and it's a day
of your life and you know it's
definitely going to open some doors for
you open your eyes open your mind yeah I
mean it's it well I agree I think
everybody should come if people want to
get in touch with you specifically
whether it's they're looking for someone
to help them with the sourcing or the
management side of things which you're
so brilliant at what's the best way to
get in touch uh so I'm on Instagram so
you can DM me on in Instagram it's
holly. character properties um we've got
a website which is
www.ar stays. co.uk well I'll leave all
your links in the description to the
video and look forward to seeing you
continue to smash it if you're watching
this I want to invite you to come and
spend the full day with me at the
property investors crash course where I
can everything I know about property
into one day you're going to learn a ton
it literally costs1 to get your ticket
I'll also leave the link in the
description until then see you next
[Music]
time